liebing lebt von der sehnsucht der
chinesen nach dem perfekten start für
ihr kind sie bietet alles an was das
baby so brauchen sollte dies ist eine
sprechende windel sie teil der mutter
mit wenn das baby pipi gemacht hat oder
wenn die körpertemperatur über 37,5 grad
steigt dann sagt sie mama ich habe
vielleicht fieber 40 cent kostet eine
windel
ein sensor alarmiert das handy der
mutter der neueste schreien der baby
industrie sie muss es unbedingt
vorführen neben babyprodukten für dinge
auch noch ein immobilienimperium sie
besitzt mehr als 460 b b hotels in der
die mütter direkt nach der geburt
einziehen können um sich verwöhnen zu
lassen
die luxus suite kostet rund 13.000 euro
im monat
das zimmer ist aber mehr als 100
quadratmeter groß ein normales zimmer
kostet zwischen 5000 bis 7000 800 euro
kunden mit einem mittleren und höheren
einkommen können sich das leisten
vor allem aber die wohlhabenden
großstädter die lobby des b b hotels in
peking wirkt wie bei einer luxusherberge
mit begrüßungskomitee für jeden gast
[Musik]
lande und ihre familie haben das geld
mieten ein zimmer für einen monat sie
gehört der gut ausgebildeten elite an
mit hochschulabschluss und job in der
internet branche selbst bei ihr aber
reicht das geld bisher nur für ein kind
wenn wir sehr schnell sehr viel geld
verdienen dann denke ich darüber nach
ein zweites kind zu haben
wir hoffen dass unser kind in
wohlhabenden verhältnissen aufwächst
die hebamme schläft bei der mutter damit
sie sich ständig um das baby kümmern
kann
landwirt noch unsicher will keine fehler
machen
der aufstieg in der chinesischen
gesellschaft ist hart und er beginnt mit
der geburt in 18 jahren soll er auf die
universität nur wenige schaffen das wir
hoffen dass unser kind bald mathematik
physik und englisch lernen kannst ich
will nicht dass mein kind im vergleich
zu anderen zurückfällt chinesische
eltern haben sehr hohe erwartungen
es ist ein wellness programm mit dem
diese generation aufwächst ein kind
kostet in china bis zum 22
lebensjahr im durchschnitt 105000 euro
die hebammen kommen meistens aus
einfacheren verhältnissen können sich
ein solches hotel & investment nicht
leisten den kinderwunsch der partei
werden sie nicht öffnen
vielleicht haben familien in der stadt
die finanziellen möglichkeiten
mehr kinder aber für menschen vom lande
wenig ist das schwierig denn nur ein
elternteil arbeitet kann die familie
nicht überleben jahrzehntelang erlaubten
chinas machthaber familie nicht mehr als
ein kind zu haben so wollten sie das
bevölkerungswachstum stoppen
wer dennoch schwanger wurde musste
abtreiben oder eine strafe zahlen
nun leitet die nation unter der immer
älter werdenden bevölkerung und die
droht bis 2050 um 28 millionen zu
schrumpfen
präsident braucht babys um seinen traum
von chinas größer zu verwirklichen
das renten und das gesundheitssystem
wird immer mehr unter druck
die wirtschaft wird schrumpfen und die
ausgaben für soziales werden steigen
lokale regierungen werden sich schwer
verschulden in der provinz heilongjiang
kann man die folgen schon spüren sie
altert am schnellsten in china das leben
es tat
die meisten sind farmer der anbau von
mais bringt nicht viel ein
dieses jahr die flut noch teile der
ernte zerstört
es gibt immer weniger kinder hier und
die eltern müssen eine schwere
entscheidung fällen
jeder will geld verdienen aber du willst
auch auf das kind aufpassen
du musst dich also entscheiden entweder
kind großziehen oder geld machen
in der stadt nachher in der provinz
heilongjiang bleiben die alten unter
sich das straßenbild verändert sich am
hauseingang suchen sie mieter für
leerstehende wohnungen fand er vorlebt
in einem dieser häuser der 50-jähriges
metzger zieht mit seiner frau ihr
enkelkind groß die eltern leben in
shanghai weil sie dort mehr verdienen
jeden monat schicken sie geld mehrere
generationen finanzieren das leben von
john
ich bin der meinung niemand auf dem land
kann ein drittes kind ernähren
niemand kann sich als zweites kind
leisten
deshalb wollen sie auch keins bahnchef
hat ehrgeizige pläne für seine einzige
enkeltochter
er hilft ihr bei den hausaufgaben aber
das reicht nicht
in wenigen monaten soll sie wohl
privaten englisch unterricht bekommen
das lebensmotto für das enkelkind hängt
an der wand
wenn du verwirrt bist wirst du lesen
wenn du alleine bist musst du denken
wenn du so willst mach deine mathematik
hausaufgaben
ich hoffe sie wird einmal reich und hat
ein glückliches leben wenn sie groß ist
hoffe ich dass sie auf eine gute
universität gehen kann und einen guten
job findet in den letzten zehn jahren
ist die bevölkerung von noch um 30
prozent geschrumpft
die stadt hat schon etwas geisterhaftes
chinas machthaber haben angst vor einer
kinderlosen zukunft scheint die realität
zu werden
auf dem lernt siehst du häuser aber
keine menschen mehr
wir sind hier die letzte generation die
letzte generation im edel b b hotel in
peking pflegen sie die babys wie
kostbarkeiten und das land fürchtet sich
vorm altwerden